what's it like being here opening night
of the Jonas Brothers tourists and
you're one of the special surprises
well Kevin it's mega exciting I mean I
still can't believe it we release run
away with daddy yankee naughty and the
Jonas Brothers first time singing in
Spanish Jamie that's not a rudder on a
rotor and I run away
now that they invited us happiness
begins tor I'm just pretty nervous are
you a little nervous to go through words
I'm super nervous it's my first time
singing next to them on stage and I've
been a crazy Jonas fans Jonas Brothers
fans since I was really young so I also
hear that you're gonna have are you
gonna have folks here tonight I have a
couple of friends over here because I
grew up in Miami so you know family's
coming and everybody's gonna go watch us
and we're just excited because it tours
looking insane it sounds incredible and
they they brought they brought something
really special there is this crossover
thing going where so many now artists
from the US are adapting the sounds of
Latin America and it's been really
successful for folks what does that mean
to you to see the crossover happening oh
it means a lot you know we just love
that Americans and people all over the
world are into Latin culture and they
feel all that love we have in our hearts
and we want to share with you guys and
our goal is for Latin music to also
become world music you know an artist
like J Balvin artists like maluma
artists like daddy yankee or doing some
amazing things and I'm just happy to be
a part of it alright your Colombian but
yes still you have a huge following in
Latin American people may not realize
they
your big deal in Latin America a little
bit of what do you mean a little bit you
are a big deal
thank God it's been fun and we're doing
a crazy tour all over Latin America
right now in Spain and a lot of sold-out
shows so hopefully we'll announce our
next US tour soon really okay so you'll
be here tonight and then we're off to
tomorrow morning I'm heading back to LA
I'm working on my third album and I'm
doing I wrote in January a song that I
think is the best song I've written in
my life and it's actually in English so
hopefully I'll release it next year was
with a big American actor who's that big
American actor can you give us a hint
who's the big American act hopefully
it'll be a girl really who knows okay
good luck knock them dead so we'll be
ready we'll come see it all right god
bless you and take care guys good luck
tonight thank you enjoy happiness begins
towards the best tour ever
[Music]